hier gehts weiter mit dem
tagesordnungspunkte 13 in dieser
sitzungswoche wehrhafte demokratie
gegenüber extremismus ist der überließ
die überschrift zugrunde liegt ein
antrag aus der unionsfraktion die sagt
dass sie zwar den aktionsplan der die
ministerin feser zum kampf gegen den
rechtsextremismus begrüße aber es müsse
weitere initiativen geben beispielsweise
gegen islamistischen terrorismus gegen
politischen islamismus sowie gegen
linksextremismus also alles was die
wehrhafte demokratie
möglicherweise oder die demokratie
insgesamt in gefahr bringen könnte
interessant dabei in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode hat es mehrere anläufe
gegeben innerhalb der großen koalition
und auch auf initiative der spd ein
demokratie fördergesetz zu verabschieden
das ist bei der union nicht
durchgedrungen jetzt also die
forderungen gegen extremismus auf der
fall auf verschiedenen ebenen allerdings
sind die schwerpunkte er gerichtet auf
maßnahmen die sich auf die abwehr und
damit auf die sicherheitsbehörden
richten mehr dazu von alexander throm
aus der unionsfraktion und da ist er
innenpolitischer sprecher
zur demokratie wird von vielen seiten
angegriffen und deswegen muss sie
wehrhaft sein und die zahlen von dieser
woche so politisch motivierten
kriminalität mahnt uns erneut sie sind
erneut auf einem höchststand wir müssen
dabei aber das gesamte spektrum des
extremismus in den blick nehmen der
staat muss mit aller konsequenz
jeglichen verfassungsfeindlichen
bestrebungen entgegen treten und schon
horst seehofer hat den rechtsextremismus
als größte gefahr für unsere demokratie
bezeichnet und eine 89 punkte katalog
gegen rechtsextremismus auf den weg
gebracht wir begrüßen es außerordentlich
dass die jetzige bundesministerin diesen
weg fortführt und das eint uns auch im
kampf gegen den rechtsextremismus
mit der koalition vieles ist richtig an
dem zehn punkte plan den sie frau
ministerin vorgelegt haben aber es ist
nicht wirklich viel neues dabei sie
übernehmen viele der punkte die auch
schon die vorgängerregierung auf den weg
gebracht hat und frau ministerin sie
nutzen das thema ja schon auch um sich
selber ein bisschen zu promoten das ist
legitim das ist völlig in ordnung und
was sie da sagen ist auch nicht das
problem
das problem ist was sie nicht sagen denn
seit amtsantritt haben sie nahezu nichts
zu dem phänomen bereichen
linksextremismus oder islamistische
terror sowie politischer islam gesagt
sie vernachlässigen diese gefahren in
eklatanter art und weise eine vierten
damen und herren
und dies
und dies obwohl ihre eigene statistik
vom dienstag dieser woche zeit dass die
gewaltbereitschaft bei den
linksextremisten besorgniserregend hoch
ist bei gewaltstraftaten also
körperverletzung und tötungsdelikten
liegen die linksextremisten auf platz
eins und dies obwohl ihre statistik
ausweist dass extremistische straftaten
aus religiöser ideologie im letzten jahr
um 50 prozent gestiegen sind das bka
wirklich die absolute mehrzahl der
straftaten mit terrorismus qualität
entfällt nach wie vor auf den phänomen
bereich religiöse ideologie das wüste
eine innenministerin alarmieren tut es
aber nicht jedenfalls haben sie dazu
nicht ausgeführt und deswegen die dieser
antrag auch dazu sie in diesem thema auf
die richtige spur zu bringen wir müssen
alle bereiche des extremismus
entsprechend berücksichtigen
und ehrlich gesagt frau fischer ich
verstehe auch nicht weshalb sie hier
bewusst so eine lücke entstehen lassen
denn nahezu alle maßnahmen ihres
zehn-punkte-plans könnten auch auf die
anderen extremismus formen angewandt
werden prävention aufklärung in schulen
sport betrieben kampf gegen hass und
hetze entwaffnung oder insbesondere auch
die aufdeckung der finanzströme
insbesondere auch in islamistischen
bereich wäre dringend geboten das ist
aber bei ihnen momentan nicht thema und
über den zehn-punkte-plan hinaus braucht
es mehr auch in dem für sie so wichtigen
thema des kampfes gegen
rechtsextremismus es braucht richtige
konsequente werkzeuge und die strukturen
gefährdern aufklären zu können bevor es
zu spät ist aber daran fehlt es bei
ihrem aktionsplan gänzlich es fehlt
insbesondere dass wir unsere
sicherheitsbehörden auch technisch
entsprechend aufrüsten union und spd
haben beispielsweise in der letzten
periode dem verfassungsschutz die
befugnis übertragen zur quellen tk grüne
und fdp haben die dazugehörige
rechtsverordnung im bundesrat blockiert
das erschwert die arbeit des
verfassungsschutzes weiter verwalten sie
dem bka beispielsweise die abwehr des
international bei einer abwehr des
internationalen terrorismus auch das
auslesen von gespeicherter nachrichten
auf messenger diensten sie stellen dem
bka bei der strafverfolgung schlechter
als den verfassungsschutz deswegen
werden wir sie auch hier tätig zu werden
weiteres thema wir brauchen längere
fristen bei der speicherung denken sie
an den mörder von walter lübcke dadurch
durchs raster gefallen ist und wir
brauchen ja auch bei minderjährigen die
möglichkeit informationen speichern zu
können denken sie etwa an die vielen es
rückkehrer etwas das ihr präsident
halten waren schon seit langem fordert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich muss feststellen die abneigung der
ampel gegenüber mehr puck ist vielleicht
auch das misstrauen gegenüber dem staat
ist offensichtlich größer als der wille
des kampfes gegen extremismus auch
rechtsextremismus sonst würden sie ihr
handeln liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sie haben jetzt die verantwortung
sie haben auch die verantwortung dafür
was sie nicht tun was sie unterlassen
dieser verantwortung werden weder die
koalition noch die ministerin momentan
gerecht herzlichen dank
alexander throm der innenpolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion hat am ende
seiner rede noch mal in nancy faeser
angesprochen die
bundesministerin die an dieser debatte
natürlich teilnimmt nächster redner
jetzt unkraut aus der spd fraktion
er ist mitglied im ausschuss für inneres
und heimat und im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium
endlich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zu beginn vielleicht zur einordnung atom
sozial wenn man sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten und ich sage das
gleiche gilt für grüne und für freie
demokraten kämpfen nicht gegen rechts um
sich zu promoten sondern sie kämpfen aus
überzeugung heraus gegen rechts und
gegen alle feinde der demokratie das
möchte ich gesagt haben und ich hoffe
dass das auch auf sie zu treten
und was sie eben gesagt hat mit dem
misstrauen gegen den staat und seine
institutionen möchte ich sie auch gerne
daran erinnern dass wir erstens schon
mal aus unserer geschichte heraus mit
unserem leben diesen staat verteidigt
haben im gegensatz zu ihnen und irgendwo
erfahren und dass wir zweitens in der
großen koalition gemeinsam mit ihnen und
stellen sie das doch nicht in abrede
acht jahre lang alles dafür getan haben
um die sicherheitsbehörden zu stärken
und diesen weg werden wir weitergehen
und ich erkläre ihnen auch gleich wie
wir das tun werden
und ich sage ihnen wenn sie in ihrem
antrag wo nach dem zweiten absatz
aufgehört hätten zu schreiben womöglich
hätten wir ihm sogar zugestimmt aber
danach wenn man weiterliest dann wird es
gerade zu gruselig in ihrem antrag
zumindest aus sicht unserer fraktion zum
beispiel die datenspeicherung von
kindern beim verfassungsschutz ein alter
ich sage es nicht ein alter wunsch ihrer
fraktion die straffung zu nennen sie das
von präventionsprogrammen wir alle
wissen doch dass sie de facto damit
kürzungen im präventionsbereich meinen
außerdem wollen sie sich eben gesagt am
allerliebsten natürlich lebenslänglich
die speicherung von personen beim
verfassungsschutz und auch noch absolut
aus der mottenkiste
gegriffen eine sogenannte
demokratieerklärung von denen die
demokratie arbeit und extremismus
prävention in diesem land leisten ihr
verhältnis das sei gesagt ihr verhältnis
zur gesellschaft ist geprägt von
misstrauen unseres von dank anerkennung
und vertrauen
aber
das ist eben der unterschied zwischen
ihnen und uns wir werden endlich das
demokratie fördergesetz beschließen und
eine solide und dauerhafte finanzierung
sicherstellen ihnen sind grundrechte bei
den befugnissen für unsere
sicherheitsbehörden nur im weg ein
hindernis für uns sind die grundrechte
der maßstab für alle befugnisse liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
herum sie haben ja gesagt die größte
gefahr in diesem land kommt von rechts
und ich finde sie sollten damit aufhören
das immer wieder zu relativieren schauen
sie in die aktuelle pmk statistik des
bundeskriminalamtes wir haben auch in
2021 doppelt so viele rechte straftaten
die linke ausländischen islamistische
straftaten zusammen doppelt so viele wie
alle anderen zusammen
sie haben sicher die fast verdreifachen
und der straftaten in der kategorie
nicht zuzuordnen vernommen wir wissen
dass sie ein großer teil in zusammenhang
mit der korona leuten der szene und
corona protesten steht die wiederum
völkisches antisemitisches unter
rechtsextremes gedankengut schlägt daher
ist die gefahr kein wunder dass die
streif frau von steuern daher ist die
gefahr von rechts garantiert noch größer
als die pmk statistik die es derzeit
abbildet zu ihrem gebetsmühlenartigen
vorwurf zu viel gegen rechts und zu
wenig gegen islamisten wir haben aktuell
75 rechte gefährder also personen denen
jederzeit einen rechtsextremistischen
terroranschlag zuzutrauen ist das
analyse tool zur einstufung der
gefährlichkeit ist beim
bundeskriminalamt übrigens erst seit ein
paar tagen im einsatz für islamisten
gibt es das schon sie wissen es seit
jahren und ich sage ihnen wir haben
nachholbedarf im kampf gegen rechts und
diese koalition wird das leisten
und es trifft sich gut dass sie hier ist
sozusagen als beleg dafür hat die
bundesministerin heute mit dem
präsidenten des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz das lagebild
rechtsextremisten reichs bürger und
selbstverwalteten sicherheitsbehörden
vorgestellt bei 327 bediensteten der
sicherheitsbehörden von bund und ländern
wurden tatsächliche anhaltspunkte für
bestrebungen gegen die freiheitliche
demokratische grundordnung festgestellt
gemessen am dreijährigen
untersuchungszeitraum gemessen an der
gesamtzahl von
355.000 100 beschäftigten in den
sicherheitsbehörden ist das natürlich
eine verschwindend geringe zahl
was für mich durchaus auch der beleg
dafür ist dass unsere
sicherheitsbehörden statt auf dem boden
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung stehen aber trotzdem
natürlich ein jeder verfassungsfeind
zählt erst recht in den
sicherheitsbehörden keiner hat was
beides sicherheitsbehörden zu suchen und
deshalb ist es gut dass es ein
konsequentes vorgehen auch ihre person
frau bundesinnenministerium dagegen gibt
und ein konsequentes vorgehen auch
dieser koalition und der ganzen
bundesregierung
den 360
grad blick den sie in ihrem antrag auch
fordern den stellen wir gerade her wir
haben das ja miterlebt er war sozusagen
16 jahre so ein bisschen aus dem blick
geraten
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union wir waren uns unter dem
demokratinnen und demokraten und das ist
mir wirklich wichtig zu sagen immer
einig dass extremismusbekämpfung und
extremismus prävention die grundpfeiler
unserer wehrhaften demokratie sind und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier an
einem strang ziehen damit demokratie
feinde nicht das vertrauen in den staat
untergraben können und wenn sie diesen
kunst konsens auf entdecken indem sie
hier einen generalverdacht gegen zivile
träger ins spiel bringen dann bewegen
sie sich als volkspartei weg von der
mitte ich sage das auch mit blick auf
andere parlamentarische eingaben von
innen fischen sind nicht am rechten rand
werden sie um wählerinnen und wählern in
der mitte der gesellschaft bleiben sie
volkspartei bleiben sie bleiben auch sie
stabil am boden der
freiheitlich-demokratischen druck vielen
dank
politische spd-fraktion in der debatte
zu einem antrag der unionsfraktion
wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus ist der titel und zu diesen
antrag jetzt steffen ja nicht aus der
fdp-fraktion mit seiner ersten rede im
parlament
pünktlich zur veröffentlichung der
fallzahlen der politisch motivierten
kriminalität im jahr 2021 bringt die
unions fraktion einen antrag zum thema
extremismus 1 die aktuellen zahlen im
bereich der pmk sind alles dem sind für
uns als demokraten nicht gleichgültig im
bereich pmk rechts sind die straftaten
im vergleich zum jahr 2020 um rund 1600
fälle zurückgegangen im bereich pmk
links gab es einen rückgang von 800
fällen ein anstieg um 150 prozent ist
jedoch im bereich pmk er sich nicht
zuordnen lässt auf hold
wenn irgendwie durch wenn wir uns mit
den begangenen straftaten befassen fällt
auf dass im jahr 20 21 von knapp 22.000
begangenen straftaten im bereich pmk
rechts mehr als die hälfte nämlich
12.000 taten propagandadelikte warum
sprechen wir hingegen von
gewaltstraftaten also insbesondere von
körperverletzungen und tötungsdelikte
legen die im jahr 20 21 von
linksextremisten begangenen taten mit
1200 fällen nach wie vor noch vor denen
von rechtsextremisten begangenen taten
mit 1040 fällen sind linksextremisten
spitzenreiter wenn es darum geht andere
menschen an der gesundheit zu schädigen
und
damit klar zu sagen jeder einzelne aus
extremistischen motiven heraus verübte
straftat ist eine zuviel und eindeutig
zu verurteilen
das heißt aber nicht dass der staat das
recht hat menschen aufgrund ihrer
meinung zu kriminalisieren und zu
extremisten zu planen als extremisten zu
brandt morgen einer pauschalen
verurteilung von menschen die
beispielsweise gegen corinna maßnahmen
spazierengehen treten wir entschieden
entgegen
es ist aber auch fröhlich zu sehen dass
die cdu inzwischen ihre sicherheits
politisches rückgrat entdeckt denn sie
hat recht wenn sie schreibt zum
staatlichen schutzauftrag gehört einen
blick der die bevölkerung im gleichen
maße von den erheblichen gefahren des
extremistischen islamismus wie vor dem
zunehmend radikalen linksextremismus
bewahrt schade ist allerdings dass ihr
das erst in der oppositionsrolle nach 16
jahren bundesregierung ein feld
andernfalls könnte sich schon in der
letzten wahlperiode den initiativen der
fdp fraktion zustimmen können
denn wenn die cdu heute befürchtet dass
unter nancy faeser oder kampf gegen
islamismus und linksextremismus in den
hintergrund tritt sage ich schon in der
wahlperiode
19 haben wir die prüfung von
verbotsverfahren gegen antifa banken die
unterbindung von finanzierung von
islamistischen moscheeverein durch
ausländische staaten die ausweisung
ausländischer hassprediger und das
verbot islamistische moscheevereinen in
deutschland gefordert
immerhin adaptieren sie heute unsere
forderungen und schlagen eine aufdeckung
der finanzströme
von islamistischen moscheevereinen vfb
wirkt also
und wir als ard setzen uns auch weiter
konsequent für die stärkung in
anerkennung der polizei als wichtige
behörde der gefahrenabwehr 1 was wir
aber nicht brauchen sind weiter und
befugnisse für unsere
verfassungsschutzbehörden stephanie der
mörder von walter lübke war dem
verfassungsschutz bekannt eines amri der
attentäter vom breitscheidplatz war dem
verfassungsschutz bekannt und das muss
man sich mal vorstellen da ein tank
einer 26 jährige internet aktivisten
ohne schulabschluss einfach mal so aus
öffentlichen quellen und mit vollkommen
legalen mitteln die angeblichen behörden
bundes service telekommunikation und
transportmanagement der bundesverwaltung
als vollständige tom organisationen des
vs
300 mitarbeiter brauchen nunmehr neue
büros und neue identitäten die kosten
gehen in die millionen und das ist genau
der verfassungsschutz der auf ein
jährliches haushaltsbudget von einer
halben milliarde euro zurückgreifen kann
ich sage ihnen klar die innere
sicherheit wird am besten von unsere
polizei geschützt einen solchen
verfassungsschutz brauchen wir nicht ich
freue mich auf die beratung im ausschuss
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen konstantin von notz und
konstantin von notz ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
und vorsitzender des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums für die nacht entlässt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
wehrhaftigkeit der demokratie muss sich
in diesen tagen ganz besonders beweisen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung wird massiv bedroht von
innen wie von außen in einem lange nicht
mehr für möglich gehaltenen ausmaß aber
diese bedrohungen verlangen nach neuen
modernen differenzierten und rom vor
allen dingen auch verfassungskonformen
sicherheitspolitischen antworten und da
findet man in ihrem antrag leider wenig
es ist vor allen dingen ein sammelsurium
ihrer alten
sicherheitspolitischen forderungen ihr
ziel ziemlich offenkundig in politische
profilschärfung zwei tage vor den wahlen
in nordrhein westfalen das verfehlen sie
meine damen und herren
und man muss es an dieser stelle einfach
mal sagen mit ihren busen narrativen
unwissenschaftlichen hufeisen negativen
haben cdu und csu hier lange viel zu
lange jahre lang die dringend notwendige
debatte über den mörderischen
rechtsextremismus in diesem land
verschleppt meine damen und herren über
200 wurde seit 1990 und die
kurskorrektur toben die kurskorrektur
seit 2017 2018 war eine von rechts
terroristischen anschlägen von einer
skandalösen zunahme
rechtsextremistischer vereinigung und
aktivitäten getriebene kurskorrektur 13
untersuchungsausschusses zum nsu eine
breite kritische berichterstattung die
zivilgesellschaft das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium dieses hauses und ein
wechsel an der spitze des bundesamtes
für verfassungsschutz war notwendig
damit das unions geführte
innenministerium endlich anerkennen dass
lange offenkundig war nämlich dass
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung die sicherheit vieler
menschen in diesem land vor allen dingen
und massiv von rechtsextremisten
gefährdet
wer dazu eine klare sprache irgendwie
nachdenkliche fragen oder sowas einen
neuen sound in ihrem antrag sucht der
sucht vergebens es ist vor allen dingen
alter wein in alten schläuchen
jetzt haben wir alle jahr am letzten
sonntag nach schleswig holstein in den
hohen norden geguckt nach kiel manche
haben sich gefreut andere weniger auf
jeden fall hat ihr kollege herr czaja
messerscharf analysiert das leder
irgendwie an der wirtschaftspolitik und
dann kam es vor allen dingen an einer
sicherheitspolitischen null toleranz
politik das ist wirklich ein lustiges
statement denn sie werden in ganz
deutschland keinen bürgerrechts und
freiheitsrechte orientierten
koalitionsvertrag finden als den in
schleswig holstein gegen die dortige
koalition aufgeschrieben hat eben keine
hatte null toleranz strategie sondern
eine an bürger und freiheitsrechten
orientierte innen und sicherheitspolitik
und da sage ich ihnen lernen sie mal was
von ja die afg stellt man kalt nicht
indem man ihre abwegigen narrativen
nacherzählt sondern indem man klare
rechtsstaatliche karte wird
bemerkenswert ist ja der jüngste
gemeinsame beschluss der präsidien von
cdu und csu in sachen sicherheitspolitik
der durchaus selbstkritisch ausfällt ist
mir aufgefallen ich zitiere deutschland
ist militärisch und sicherheitspolitisch
hochgradig vulnerable und weiter
strategisches denken und operative
wehrhaftigkeit müssen eine wesentlich
höhere politische priorität erhalten das
sind wahre worte gelassen ausgesprochen
nach 16 jahren durchgängiger
verantwortung von cdu und csu ins
verteidigungsministerium und
innenministerium sieht es um diese
beiden zentralen felder sehr schlecht
aus und deswegen ist es wichtig und
richtig dass die ampelkoalition in
diesen bereichen einen besonders
ehrgeizig und schönen koalitionsvertrag
hat wir geben es alles an die hybriden
bedrohungen die des
informationskampagnen die dramatischen
probleme bei der it sicherheit die wir
von ihm geerbt haben alle formen des
antisemitismus von rechts den aus der
mitte der gesellschaft und natürlich
auch den von links und den salafistisch
geprägten den rechtsextremismus genauso
wie den islamismus dass sie petrom hier
so bedeutungsschwanger vortragen ist
eine vollkommene selbstverständlichkeit
wir müssen überall hin gucken wo es
gefährlich ist und das tun wir und
einsatzfähig zu müssen muss noch
loswerden weil ich den kollegen straffer
sehe und die kollegin mihalic und renner
im
untersuchungsausschuss zum
breitscheidplatz waren sie es die
gebremst haben und verschleppt haben die
aufklärung des schwersten salafistischen
anschlages in der bundesrepublik
deutschland der in ihrer verantwortung
zeit passiert ist viele netzwerke und
probleme konnten wir nicht aufdecken
weil sie auf der bremse gestanden haben
auch in mecklenburg vorpommern bringen
und jetzt mal letzter punkt wegen der
wichtigkeit von rechtsstaatlichen und
verfassungskonform antworten drolliger
weise nehmen sie ja bezug auf die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
zum bayerischen landesverfassungsschutz
gesetzt haben sechsundzwanzigster april
diesen jahres
monatelang hat die csu in einer wirklich
traumhaften art und weise gegen die
gesamte staatsrechtslehrer gegen alle
die gefragt wurden könnte das eventuell
nicht doch verfassungskonform sein
dieses gesetz durchgebracht und sie
haben einen kollateralschaden
biblischen ausmaßes angerichtet weil
dieses urteil mal ganz viele instrumente
einfach abgeräumt und jetzt trauen sie
sich ernsthaft hier in den antrag zu
schreiben jetzt soll die ampel aber mal
schnell nach fähigen war leider viele
definitiven gemacht haben nicht
verfassungskonform sind das ist ein
treppenwitz meine damen und herren und
deswegen
kann man nur froh sein dass sich die
ampel auf den weg gemacht hat eine
seriöse
wissenschaftsbasierte evidenzbasierte
sicherheitspolitik zu machen und ich
freue mich auf unseren gemeinsamen weg
herzlichen dank
sagt konstantin von notz der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen in dieser
debatte über ein unionsantrag zum thema
wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus und dazu spricht jetzt
martina renner aus der linksfraktion wo
sie innenpolitische sprecherin ist
der demokratischen fraktion ja für uns
demokratinnen und demokraten muss die
verteidigung von demokratie und
rechtsstaat gegen angriffe eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein es geht um
den schutz von leib und leben alle
menschen die in unserem land leben
vor dem hintergrund der anschläge der
letzten jahr bedeutet dies vor allem
dass wir gegen rassisten antisemiten und
neonazis kämpfen müssen und das
gemeinsame
cdu csu wie hier diesen antrag vorgelegt
hat ist in den letzten 16 jahren bei der
bekämpfung von rassistischer gewalt und
rechts terror fulminant gescheitert sie
hatten 16 jahre zeit das thema anzugehen
trotz der schlussfolgerung aus dem nsu
untersuchungsausschüssen ist nichts
passiert die morgen von hannah hanna und
kassel konnten geschehen und auch danach
wurde aus den reihen der union die von
rechten netzwerken ausgehende gefahr
banalisiert oder sogar schlimmer sie
leugneten zum beispiel um ein beispiel
zu nennen entsprechende strukturen im
polizei und bundeswehr
sie loben auch heute hier wird den
vormaligen innenminister seehofer dafür
dass er ende 2020 einen maßnahmenkatalog
zur bekämpfung von rechtsextremismus
erarbeitet haben ende 2020 neun jahre
nach der selbstheilung des nsu sowas
vorzutragen wäre mir peinlich
ihrem antrag heißt es auch dass es nach
mittlerweile sechs monate im amt von
seitens der innenministerin feser an
einer grundhaften befassung mit den
gefahren des islamistischen terrorismus
mangele
islamistischer terrorismus ist eine
gefahr für die demokratie
dann habe ich aber eine frage was haben
scheuten den bisher kannst du das bitte
ich auch der war mal innenminister wir
uns fast vergessen und horst seehofer
getan wenn die innenminister der cdu csu
geliefert hätten dann bräuchten sie
diesen antrag gar nicht
ich muss meinen kollegen
konstantin von notz recht geben was er
hier zum breitscheidplatz
untersuchungsausschuss gesagt hat das
innenministerium unter sofort alles
dafür getan um die aufklärung des
anschlages zu blockieren und es gibt ein
zweites nach islamistischen wie rechts
terroristischen anschlägen sind cdu/csu
nicht bereit wäre in stein gemeißelten
annahmen über das funktionieren der
sicherheitsarchitektur zu überdenken und
genau diese haltung spiegelt auch ihr
antrag wieder
das liegt auch daran dass es hier wieder
vor allem um extremisten geht links
rechts hauptsache ist muss sie folgen
stur den begrifflichkeiten des
geheimnisses die mitte ist vermeintlich
schön raus dann habe ich eine zweite
frage an sie wenn ihnen der
verfassungsschutz so heiliges warum
haben sie dann maßen zu ihrem chef
gemacht eine person die einstellungen
verkörpert diese fiel mit ihrem antrag
bekämpfen wollen bis heute zur causa
maßen aufklärung fehlanzeige
das muss auch sein noch ein wort zu
neuen bundesregierung die soll
gefahrenanalyse gelingen wenn du über
23.000 straftaten haben die papiere
nicht zuzuordnen landen diese einstufung
konterkarierte den ursprünglichen zweck
der statistik 2001 eingeführt um endlich
ein rechtes ein realistisches bild zu
rechten tötungsdelikten zu bekommen ich
glaube hier muss die bundesregierung
halten handeln und diese falsche und
ihre leitende einordnung
offensichtlicher rechter gewalt und
straftaten zu ändern vielen dank
martina renner für die linksfraktion und
hier wird jetzt folgen linda teuteberg
aus der fdp-fraktion mitglied im
ausschuss für inneres und heime
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass unsere demokratie wehrhaft
sein müssen nach innen und nach außen
dass es wahrlich offensichtlicher in
diesen tagen als es eigentlich schon
zuvor war das zeigt der russische
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und es
zeigen leide auch die neuesten zahlen
zur politisch motivierten kriminalität
die die bundesinnenministeriums in
dieser woche vorgestellt hat sie zeigen
einen neuen höchststand und das in
vielen bereichen in vielen bereichen von
extremismus verschiedenen phänomen
bereichen politisch motivierter
kriminalität und was wir nicht brauchen
das ist auch nicht anders als noch in
den letzten jahren ist irgendein ranking
oder hierarchien welche art von
extremismus oder kriminalität schlimmer
oder weniger schlimm sei oder die
größere bedrohung wir brauchen den
rundumblick und das klare eintreten des
freiheitlichen rechtsstaates gegen
jeglichen extremismus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch gegen
jede form der menschen oder demokratie
verachtung es gibt keinerlei moralische
überlegenheit irgendeine ausprägung von
extremismus und es kann übrigens auch
für menschenverachtung keinen rabatt
geben weder kulturell noch für irgendein
politisches lager wo immer wir sie
wahrnehmen
[Musik]
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen besonders
beschämend und besorgen müssen uns die
auch erneut auf einem höchststand
befindlichen zahl antisemitischer taten
wir haben eine besondere verantwortung
dafür dass jüdisches leben in unserem
land sicher und selbstbestimmt
stattfinden kann und dafür dass nicht
wir uns das attestieren sondern das
jüdinnen und juden selbst darauf
vertrauen
und deshalb gilt
egal in welchem gewand egal in welcher
ausprägung jede form des antisemitismus
ist gleichermaßen inakzeptabel und wir
müssen ja entschieden entgegentreten als
rechtsstaat als gesellschaft und auch
jeder und jede einzelne von uns wo sie
uns in gesprächen begegnen zu
widersprechen wir müssen die
gesellschaftlichen türen gegen anti
gegen antisemitismus gegen
menschenverachtendes gedankengut fest
verschließen damit es auf reale türen
wir in halle nicht ankommt
und
das finde ich übrigens einen seltsamen
kontrast zwischen dem aktuellen
wirklichen ernst der lage einerseits und
den alten reflexen die in dieser debatte
wieder auftauchen und ich will da zwei
beispiele nennen zum allen liebe
kollegin kollegen von der union das ist
nicht der richtige anlass für die
altbekannten forderungen natürlich muss
der rechtsstaat wehrhaft sein und da
muss man auch sachlich über befugnisse
diskutieren können aber hier wie in
anderen bereichen geht das zauberwort
unserer verfassung verhältnismäßigkeit
und dann daran hat sich nichts verändert
und zum anderen
weil eben neue phänomene er eine neue
nachdenklichkeit erfordern und nicht die
alten reflexe muss ich auch zu den
kollegen der linken sagen verändern wenn
wir neue schwer einzuordnende phänomene
haben dann finde ich es ist besser dass
das auch offen kommuniziert wird bei der
kriminalitätsstatistik als wie sie es
vorschnell phänomene in alter schubladen
zu packen war das in ihr weltbild besser
passt verschwörungs erzählungen und
vieles andere gibt es nicht nur in einem
politischen lager und ich finde das
sollte uns eher nachdenklich machen so
sehr die sicherheitsbehörden gegen jeden
der den staat delegitimieren will klar
vorgehen müssen sollten wir über die
ursachen nur die motive gründlich
nachdenken und nicht alles so wie sie es
gern möchten in eine rechte schublade
packen sondern die komplexität der
phänomene wahrnehmen und beschreiben
und ebenfalls
möglich und die müssen uns besorgen sind
die erhöhten zahlen bei angriffen gegen
mandats und amtsträger auch hier müssen
wir ganz klar sagen wer
repräsentanten unserer demokratie
unseres rechtsstaates angreift greift
uns alle an und das ist keine frage der
politischen opportunität der mandats und
amtsträger angreift derzeit damit auch
seinen mangelnden respekt zum beispiel
vor den wahl entscheidungen der
bürgerinnen und bürger die diese person
legitimiert haben hier darf es kein
verständnis dafür geben wir müssen
glaubwürdig dafür einstehen dass unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
so viele friedliche und legale
möglichkeiten bietet sich politisch zu
beteiligen und da kann es auch keinen
blankoscheck geben für selbsternannte
aktivisten recht und gesetz gelten für
jedermann in unserem land teuteberg
gestorben eine zwischenfrage
daseinsvorsorge für unsere demokratie
das muss für uns auch bedeuten respekt
vor dem ehrenamt zum beispiel auch in
politischen parteien bessere
rahmenbedingungen für das ehrenamt in
unserem land darauf kommt es an die
brauchen vieles mehr vorbeugung
prävention politische bildung dazu wird
mein kollege stephan seite sprechen auch
auf unser verhalten in jeder politischen
debatte kommt es an wie groß der respekt
für die politischen institutionen in
unserem land ist vielen dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
hat das wort zu einer kurzintervention
die kollegin renner
danke frau vorsitzende dass sie mir die
gelegenheit geben auf die ausführungen
kollegin teuteberg einzugehen sie haben
ihr vorgeworfen dass wir die neuen
phänomene wie sie es nennen in der
korona leugne szene zu unrecht rechts
bezeichnen diese seien vielmehr
indifferent in ihrer politischen
bewertung ich will ihnen sagen das was
wir dort vorfinden sind nicht einfach
verschwörungs erzählung das sind
antisemitische negative die weit
zurückgehen auch in die vergangenheit es
sind sozialdarwinistische vorstellungen
das recht der stärkere soll sich
durchsetzen sie bekämpfen den staat um
ein autoritäres regime zu errichten sie
lehnen die institutionen sie können alle
einstellungs ebenen des
rechtsextremismus durchgehend sie finden
alle diese facetten auch den rassismus
zum beispiel in diesem anti asiatischen
moment in der dort auch gefunden haben
in der korona leuten dass sie den wir
müssen endlich anerkennen sie ist das
ergebnis einer rechten mobilisierung und
einer rechten ideologie danke
sie dürfen antworten sie
kollegin renner sie bestätigen gerade
mit ihren einlassungen all das was ich
meinte nämlich die ignoranz gegenüber
dass es sowohl es muss leider auch
autoritäres denken und vieles mehr nicht
nur in einem politischen lager gibt dass
es das auch auf der linken seite durch
ausgibt und vereinfachte
geschichtsbilder all das bestätigen ist
hier leider damit ich habe keine
einordnung vorgenommen sondern haben
beschrieben den respekt davor dass wenn
sicherheitsbehörden ist eine tat nicht
eindeutig einem bestimmten politischen
seite zuordnen können dass man das dann
auch so redlich kommunizieren sollte und
das für uns mit neuen phänomen
auseinandersetzen sollten hat eben
nichts mit verharmlosung sondern mit
ernsthaftigkeit zu tun
wir fahren fort in der debatte nächster
redner für die cdu csu fraktion ist dr
stefan hack
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie das haben die väter
und mütter unseres grundgesetzes so
festgelegt aus gutem grund die
geschichte war ihr bitterer lehrmeister
und den jahrzehnten in denen unsere
verfassung nun geltung hat haben wir
immer wieder mit neuen herausforderungen
konfrontiert das gilt für die äußere
sicherheit aber insbesondere auch für
die innere sicherheit unseres landes
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
am dienstag von der
bundesinnenministerium vorgestellt
statistik zum jahr 2021 und den dort
politisch motivierten straftaten gibt
uns allen anlass zur sorge 2021 gab es
im vergleich zum vorjahr mit einem
zuwachs von 23 prozent einen deutlichen
anstieg von politisch motivierten
straftaten mit über 55.000 delikten
befindet sich die politisch motivierte
kriminalität auf dem höchsten stand seit
der einführung dieser statistik im jahr
2001 und insbesondere der anstieg sie
haben es gesagt frau kollegin teuteberg
antisemitischer gewalt hatten um 29
prozent ist erschreckend und bedarf eine
entschlossene reaktion auf seiten von
staat und gesellschaft
mit kolleginnen kollegen der mord an dr
walter lübke der rassistisch motivierte
anschlag von hanau
und auch der anti semitische anschlag in
halle haben uns jungs dorf äußerst
schmerzhafte art und weise vor augen
geführt dass rechtsextreme gewalt noch
immer die größte gefahr für unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
darstellt da ist es richtig dass die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung im
vergangenen mai unter der federführung
von bundesinnenminister seehofer ins
leben gerufen 89 punkte plan umgesetzt
hat und sie das gestehen wir gerne zu
hier nochmal eigene schwerpunkte gesetzt
haben aber wir dürfen dort nicht stehen
bleiben zur wahrung unserer freiheit
muss politischer extremismus jeglicher
couleur bekämpft werden und deshalb
wundern wir uns schon frau ministerin
warum nach einem knappen halben jahr am
abend wir noch keine konkreten maßnahmen
zum kampf gegen islamistischen gegen
extremistischen islamismus von ihnen
kennen anschläge wie auf dem berliner
breitscheidplatz wie in paris im
november 2015 haben unseren ganzen
kontinent ins herz getroffen und die
gefahr durch islamistischen terror auch
hier in deutschland ist weiterhin hoch
wir fordern daher ein entschlossenes
vorgehen und die erarbeitung eines
aktionsplans gegen radikale islamisten
islamistische bestrebungen auch hier in
deutschland dafür
dafür brauchen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden eine gute
personalausstattung vor allem aber das
richtige handwerkszeug wir haben das in
der von uns geführten regierung erst
möglich und mit großem nachdruck
verfolgt und ich möchte sie hier
weiterhin auffordern starten sie den
verfassungsschutz insbesondere im
bereich der
telekommunikationsüberwachung mit
weitreichenden befugnissen aus schaffen
sie die voraussetzungen dafür
um die bestmögliche überwachung
terroristischer gruppen zu ermöglichen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wer
im auftrag des staates mit öffentlichen
fördermitteln im bereich der extremismus
prävention tätig wird wer muss und das
ist uns schon wichtig auf dem boden
unseres grundgesetzes stehen und deshalb
fordern wir die einführung einer
demokratie treueerklärung in
förderbescheiden damit träger
insbesondere von präventionsprojekten
sich eindeutig zum fundament unserer
gemeinsamen werteordnung bekennen
wir dürfen jedenfalls nicht akzeptieren
wir dürfen nicht akzeptieren wenn
diejenigen die rechtsextremismus und
rassismus bekämpfen wollen gleichzeitig
hass und gewalt gegen polizei und unsere
sicherheitskräfte für meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren auch der
militanten linksextremismus stellt in
deutschland eine schwerwiegende
bedrohung dar ich finde das sollten wir
hier nicht unerwähnt lassen frau
kollegin wenn gewalttätige aufmärsche
tätliche angriffe auf polizei auf
sicherheitsbehörden sind leider keine
seltenheit
wir fordern dass sie sich darum stärker
kümmern wir brauchen eine bessere
aufklärung der linksextremistischen
szene und gegen die zunehmende
radikalisierung und gewaltbereitschaft
linksextremistischer gruppierungen
schützen sie unsere demokratie und
stärken sie unsere sicherheitsbehörden
und zwar ohne scheuklappen unsere
unterstützung ist ihnen aber sicher
ärztlichen
stefan hack aus der unions fraktion
betont am ende seiner rede noch mal die
gefahr von links durch linksextremisten
die bundesinnenministerium hat heute
morgen einen bericht zur rechtsextremist
mir den sicherheitsbehörden vorgelegt
und festgestellt dass unter den
bediensteten der sicherheitsbehörden von
bund und ländern innerhalb von drei
jahren
327 mitarbeiter aufgefallen sind die
bezüge zum rechtsextremismus oder zur
szene der sogenannten reichs bürger und
selbst verwalter haben hier am pult spd
schierenbeck aus der spd fraktion
antrag den rechtsextremismus ist derzeit
für die größte gefahr für unser
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
und nicht nur ich stimme an dieser
stelle mit der union über ein sondern
die gesamten fraktionen der csp den
grünen und der fdp das können sie sogar
nachlesen koalitionsvertrag seit der 107
zahl der
3587 ich zitiere
rechtsextremismus ist derzeit die größte
bedrohung unserer demokratie
die zahlen zeigen eindeutig dass die
fälle von rechts motivierter
kriminalität sehr hoch sind höher als
die der linken die der religiösen oder
die der ausländischen ideologie die
zahlen zeigt auch wie dringend es ist
gegen den rechtsextremismus wirksam
vorzugehen wenn die von rechtem
gedankengut
geprägten straftaten doppelt so hoch
sind wie die der linken dann muss uns
doch allen zeigen dass wir zuerst
dagegen vorgehen müssen dass wir uns
erst damit beschäftigen müssen dem hass
und der hetze und der gewalt von rechts
einhalt zu gebieten
verstehen sie nicht richtig jede
straftat ist eine zu viel jede
gewaltanwendung ist eine zu viel jede
gewaltanwendung ist zu verurteilen
denn wir haben auch schon
linksextremer ausschreitungen gesehen
bilder von vermummten menschen die autos
anzünden um systemkritik auszudrücken
das ansinnen eines autos ist aber keine
systemkritik das ist erstmal
sachbeschädigung sachbeschädigung ist
übrigens auch das feld in dem von links
motivierte täter ihnen sich am
häufigsten cetin und damit möchte ich
zum nächsten punkt kommen
sachbeschädigung ist die beschädigung
einer sache es wird etwas beschmierte
kaputtgemacht angezündet das wird mit
aller konsequenz nach als strafrechtlich
verfolgt dennoch können wir diese dinge
reparieren was wir nicht reparieren
können das sind die angriffe auf die
seele seines fremdenfeindliche
antisemitische
islamfeindlich oder volksverhetzende
äußerungen äußerungen gegen die sexuelle
orientierung oder identität all diese
äußerungen hinterlasse spuren in den
lebens biografien von menschen das sind
verletzungen kunden die nicht sichtbar
sind und die die geschädigten auf die
ganzes leben lang mit sich tragen werden
solche äußerungen kommen in der masse
von rechts und deswegen lohnt es sich zu
sagen dass rechtsextremismus nicht nur
unsere demokratie bedroht sondern uns
demokratinnen bereits angreift
fremdenfeindlichkeit antisemitismus oder
volksverhetzung sind häufig nicht so gut
zu erkennen wie zum beispiel ein
brennendes auto und genau weil diese
angriffe auf die demokratie so schwer zu
erkennen sind sollten wir mit aller
macht daran arbeiten sie als erste zu
verhindern wir müssen mit aller kraft
den aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
umsetzen wir dürfen die opfer von
rechtsextremisten nicht allein lassen
und wir müssen mandatsträgerinnen vor
angriffen schützen wir müssen und die
demokratische streitkultur fördern die
politische bildung stärken und die
medienkompetenz steigern
wir müssen die hetze im internet
bekämpfen verschwörungs ideologien
entkräften und so der radikalisierung
vorbeugen wir müssen rechtsextremist in
den entwaffnen und rechtsextreme
netzwerke zerschlagen
wir müssen mit sachverstand dar
extremismus in jeder form zu bekämpfen
gefühle sind ein schlechter berater wenn
es um nichts weniger geht also um unsere
demokratie
wir brauchen mehr erkenntnisse wenn wir
extrem ist ihnen effektiv bekämpfen
wollen die periodische
sicherheitsbericht wird uns langfristig
dabei helfen tendenzen und ursachen zu
erkennen und lösungsansätze zu finden
ich habe zum gehen meiner rede die
koalitionsvertrag erwähnt dass die
koalition der cdu csu bestimmt es tut
mir leid wenn sie den eindruck gewonnen
haben dass wir uns nicht nur mit den
dringendsten und größten problemen
beschäftigen es geht natürlich weiter im
koalitionsvertrag ich zitiere wir treten
alle verfassungsfeindlichen
gewaltbereiten bestrebungen entschieden
entgegen
rechtsextremismus islamismus
verschwörungs ideologien
linksextremismus oder jede andere form
von extremismus
sehr verehrte damen und herren
von 2000 bis
2021 war das innenministerium in der
hand der union die in ihrem antrag
selbst schreibt dass die zahl der
extremisten seit jahren zunimmt und
scheinbar haben sie viel zu wenig
unternommen um dieser entwicklung
einhalt zu gebieten nun haben wir mit
nancy faeser eine kluge und starke frau
die mit entschlossenheit und
fachkenntnis ihr amt ausübt mit ihr
gemeinsam werden wir als fortschritt
gewandte koalition entschieden gegen
jegliche art von extremismus vorgehen
dem antrag der cdu csu werden nichts mit
dem erst unzureichend vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
endlich ihren weg waren das aus der spd
fraktion die am ende ihrer rede noch mal
auf die früheren bundesinnenminister
verwiesen hat
der union vor hält deshalb im bereich
extremismus in den vergangenen jahren zu
wenig getan zu haben der nächste redner
in dieser debatte ist christian wirth
und er kommt aus der afg fraktion also
bei manchen vor webber und aus dem
linken spektrum von giorgio ein glaube
keiner statistik die du nicht selbst
gefälscht hast der vorliegende antrag
der cdu csu fraktion enthielt vieles
richtig kein wunder sind einige
forderungen die wir der letzten
legislaturperiode gefordert haben
extremismus ob von links oder
islamistisch holt da natürlich auch
rechtsextremismus muss bekämpft werden
es freut uns dass mittlerweile auch eine
union die einseitige fokussierung auf
dem phänomen bereich rechtsextremismus
durch ministerin feser kritisiert auch
die forderung nach der erneuten
einführung der sogenannten
extremismusklausel unterstützen wir
ausdrücklich es handle sich dabei um
eine der ersten anträge der fraktionen
in der letzten legislaturperiode die
extremismusklausel soll kurz gesagt
verhindern dass linksextremistische und
islamistische strukturen über
steuermittel verdeckt finanziert werden
welche für den kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus ausgelobt werden
abgeschafft wurde der extremismusklausel
für die cdu csu nur zur erinnerung von
manuela schwesig im einvernehmen mit
thomas de maizière im kabinett drei
unter merkel
wie wichtig auch der kampf gegen
linksextremismus ist zeigt die ende
april erfolgte anschlagsserie auf
ladengeschäfte des modelabels thor
steinar in der bundesweit konzertierten
aktion erfüllten zeitgleich mehrere farb
und buttersäure anschläge bei denen noch
personen und tieren zu schaden kamen
trauriger höhepunkt war die tat in
erfurt bei der auf eine wehrlose auf dem
boden liegende frau von mehreren
maskierten linksextremisten mit
schlagstöcken auf kopf beine füße
eingedroschen wurde anschließend wurde
das opfer zum abschied noch reizgas ins
gesicht gesprüht der fall erinnert an
das vorgehen der linksextremistische
gefährder zelle um nina engel die gefahr
durch islamismus die uns allen große
sorge bereiten sollte möchte ich anhand
folgender zahlen verdeutlichen im jahre
20 21 leitete generalbundesanwalt für
folgende phänomen bereiche er mit uns
verfahren ein
rechtsextremismus terrorismus sechs
verfahren
linksextremismus terrorismus zehn
islamistisch motivierte extremismus
terrorismus ganze
258 verfahren so viel die meisten gefahr
geht von rechts aus bezüglich der von
der union geforderte großen der
ausweitung der befugnisse für den
verfassungsschutz möchte ich die
kollegen es vorhin erwähnt an die
ohrfeige des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
bezüglich das sicherheitsgesetz der cdu
in bayern erinnern
generell dürfe es in allen gut tun die
den instrumentierten verfassungsschutz
unterstützt haben die letzten
legislaturperiode wenn er nicht mit dem
innenministerium unterstellt werde
sondern politisch neutral agieren können
den hebel sollten wir uns gedanken
machen darüber weiß und stehen wir zu
vielen dank
vielen dank natürlicher dafür wird
als nächster lettern das wort die
kollegin dr bündnis 90/die grünen und
sie es erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin ihrer fraktion sehr
geehrter herr präsident meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union mit ihrem antrag haben sie
gleich mehrere alte kamellen aus der
schublade gekramt das haben meine
vorrednerin und vorredner ihnen schon
eindrücklich dargelegt mehr überwachung
von kommunikation gerne auch von
minderjährigen misstrauen gegenüber
zivilgesellschaftlichen initiativen et
cetera pp kann man alles nachlesen
aber wenn wir zurückblicken auf die
letzten 16 jahre da können wir
feststellen dass diese zeit gerade nicht
von einem erfolgreichen kampf gegen
extremisten und staatsfeinde geprägt war
ganz im gegenteil man könnte sogar von
einer wohlfühl zeit für rechtsextreme
und islamisten sprechen
der nicht verhinderte anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz der nsu die anschläge
in halle und hanau der mord an dr walter
lübke die massive rechtsextreme und
islamistische vernetzung all das fand
unter den augen der sicherheitsbehörden
stadt als sie von der union
verantwortung getragen haben und wenn
man sich jetzt ihren antrag anschaut
dann fragt man sich schon warum sie zum
beispiel als die aktionspläne die sie
jetzt vollmundig fordern die übrigens
völlig inhaltsleer sind nicht schon
früher erarbeitet haben denn die sicher
probleme mit denen des aktuellsten haben
die sind doch nicht neu wir sind doch
jetzt nicht plötzlich nach der
bundestagswahl vom himmel gefallen ich
kann ihnen gar nicht aufzählen mit wie
vielen anträgen kleinen anfragen
unzähligen debatten hier im deutschen
bundestag in etlichen
untersuchungsausschüssen haben wir fast
schon verzweifelt versucht sie
wachzurütteln meine damen und herren
aber stattdessen haben sie sich an
instrumente geklammert die entweder
verfassungswidrig sind wie sie
regelmäßig bescheinigt bekommen haben
oder völlig nutzlos waren und genau das
machen sie jetzt weiter sie ist
inhaltlich leergelaufen meine damen und
herren
ein wechsel an der spitze des
innenministeriums war dringend nötig und
dem koalitionsvertrag beschäftigen wir
uns intensiv mit der aufarbeitung der
sicherheitspolitik der letzten jahre die
enorme bedeutung der zivilgesellschaft
im kampf gegen rassismus antisemitismus
rechtsextremismus und jegliche formen
der demokratiefeindlichkeit wurde
einfach viel zu lange von ihnen verkannt
wir sehen das schon lange und haben sie
auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
dass diese sicherheitsprobleme ohne die
wichtige arbeit zivilgesellschaft
zivilgesellschaftlicher initiativen
nicht zu lösen sind radikalisierung
spiralen bespricht man eben nicht mit
der überwachung minderjähriger oder mit
ausrufen der kommunikationsüberwachung
oder mit extremismus klauseln
förderanträgen sondern mit erprobten der
radikalisierung programm und
vernünftiger prävention das know how ist
vorhanden wir müssen es nur besser
mit dem demokratie fördergesetz werden
wir die arbeit von
zivilgesellschaftlichen initiativen
strukturell absichern und damit den
kampf gegen demokratie und
menschenfeindlichkeit massiv stärken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
nicht nur um eines
untersuchungsausschuss sondern auch mit
vielen jahren wesen kollegen mit herrn
von notz mit martina renner mit benjamin
strasser im untersuchungsausschuss zum
anschlag auf dem breitscheidplatz
mitgearbeitet und über ihre nicht
erfolgt der aufklärung diesem
zusammenhang gerade sie atom also dass
sie sich hier gerade getraut haben ist
schon wirklich stark ja wenn man ihr
engagement diesem untersuchungsausschuss
noch mal revue passieren lässt
aber wir haben uns in diesen ausschüssen
auch wirklich intensiv mit
extremistischen bedrohungen auch mit der
vernetzung gefasst aber vor allem auch
mit der extrem reformbedürftigen
sicherheitsarchitektur die ampel
koalition geht das jetzt an wie werden
die sicherheitsarchitektur einer
gesamtbetrachtung unterziehen und die
arbeit auf allen ebenen effektiver
machen wir werden die analysefähigkeit
der sicherheitsbehörden stärken die
grenzüberschreitende polizeiliche
zusammenarbeit verbessern und mit einer
gesamtstrategie aus prävention der
radikalisierung und effektiver
gefahrenabwehr die extremismusbekämpfung
entscheidend voranbringen
wir werden uns weiter
wissenschaft mit der radikalisierung von
sogenannten querdenkern befassen eine
absolute notwendigkeit angesichts der
hohen gewaltbereitschaft und der
massiven des informationskampagnen die
wir seit beginn der pandemie erleben und
jetzt sehen wir wie die gleichen
verschwörungs ideologen mit den putin
verschwören mitlaufen das darf jetzt
nicht aus dem blick geraten meine damen
und herren
und
noch eine bemerkung zum schluss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union
ehemaliger bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer hat erkannt dass vom
rechtsextremismus die größte bedrohung
für die demokratie aus geht's das haben
sie ja auch in ihrem antrag geschrieben
bevor dann aber das große aber kommt tun
sie sich doch bitte einen gefallen und
uns allen auch fallen sie mit ihrer
hufeisen logik nicht hinter diese
erkenntnis zurück sondern unterstützen
sie uns jetzt bei dem was nun zu tun ist
vielen dank
irene mihalic höhe die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen war übrigens früher mal
polizeibeamtin dann polizei
wissenschaften und kriminologie studiert
mit abschluss im buch nächste rednerin
in dieser debatte ist petra nicolaisen
aus der unionsfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in genau
zehn tagen steht er 73 jahrestag des
grundgesetzes bevor und das grundgesetz
verkörpert doch die wehrhaftigkeit
unserer demokratie ein fundament das
bewusst ein schutzmechanismus gedacht
ist um unsere demokratische um unser
staatsverständnis vor missbrauch zu
schützen und unsere werte zu bewahren
und auch wenn unsere verfassung auf
papier geschrieben ist das grundgesetz
ist für mich ein reißfestes fundament
und das muss es auch bleiben
das bedeutet und das bedeutet natürlich
gerade jetzt dass die bundesregierung
mehr dafür tun muss die geistigen und
gewalttätigen an dürfe auf unsere
verfassung müssen verhindert werden
ministerin und diese angriffe dürfen
nicht zur zerreißprobe für unsere
demokratischen und freiheitlichen
grundsätze werden liebe frau ministerin
die zahlen auf die ist eben schon
eingegangen worden die sie am montag
veröffentlicht haben zum anstieg
politisch motivierter straftaten
machen es ganz deutlich es besteht
handlungsbedarf
und das in nahezu wie bereits berichtet
in allen bereichen gegen hass
kriminalität im internet gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit und antisemitismus
gegen gewalt sowohl an bürgerinnen und
bürgern politikerinnen und politikern
und gegen die polizei
und die zahlen sprechen
und es ansprechen zugleich für eine
genauere erkennung der straftaten das
müssen wir mit konsequenten maßnahmen
bekämpfen und flankieren denn wehrhafte
demokratie bedeutet für mich dass der
start dieser konfrontation nicht aus dem
wege geht er stellt sich gewalt
ausgrenzung und spaltung entgegen und da
braucht es keine lippenbekenntnisse
vielmehr braucht es auch wirkungs
stärkere befugnisse und deshalb muss der
grundsatz gelten wenn politisch
motivierte kriminalität schirmer wird
und das wird sie dann muss auch die
antwort des staates dar auch spürbar und
konsequent sein und es darf kein zögern
mehr geben damit muss schluss sein
es bleibt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ein zweifel und zugleich die frage wofür
die bundesregierung eigentlich steht
will die bundesregierung eine leuchtturm
politik die nach außen hin scheint aber
das innere nicht wirklich beleuchtet
oder wollen sie eine politische realität
gestalten die es nicht schafft vertrauen
in staat und gemeinschaft
sowie die grundsätze von demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu wahren
oder wollen sie wirklich entschieden
gegen demagogen extremisten und
rassisten die die streitbarkeit unserer
demokratie missbrauchen vorgehen der
vorliegen der antrag einer fraktion ist
aus diesem grund ein weckruf an die
bundesregierung zeigen sie haltung
ergreifen sie die möglichkeiten um den
feinden der demokratie dem hass dem
terror und der gewalt sowie auch der
angst und der verschwörung und der
verleumdung und allen ihren techniken
das handwerk legen zu können
deshalb
[Applaus]
deshalb fordern wir sie auf
und ich würde die vier punkte im kern
gern noch mal wiederholen setzen sie
endlich einen aktionsplan auf gegen
islamistischen terror und gegen
linksextremismus überprüfen sie die
wirksamkeit von präventionsprogrammen
und lieber kollege krutsch da geht es in
keinster weise um kürzungen stärken sie
auch die sicherheits und justizbehörden
für eine bessere erkennung und
bekämpfung und besonders um den
betroffenen menschen zu helfen und zu
schützen und viertens starken sie
endlich die behörden mit wirksameren
befugnissen aus eine bundesregierung
muss schließlich bewahren was wir aus
überzeugung vertreten und tüten und die
fundamente einer gesunden demokratie von
kunst und freiheit der mensch ein
mögliches rezept dafür haben wir ihnen
vorgelegt jetzt sind sie am ziel und an
jetzt sind sie gefordert zu entscheiden
und lieber kollege krank häufig
benötigen ein die letzte
legislaturperiode einsatz herr präsident
bitte ich erinnere mich an eine
eigentlich ganz gute zusammenarbeit aber
ihre rede eben ging unter die
gürtellinie und wenn einer die
sicherheitsbehörden nicht gestärkt hat
in der letzten legislaturperiode dann
war es die spd
vielen dank frau leiden so den
stillstand änderung der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der cdu fraktion kann
sich schon mal darauf einstellen dass
hoffmann nur noch 4 minuten statt fünf
minuten nicht als nächster redner hat
die kollege dr stefan seite
fdp-fraktion das wort mit seiner ersten
parlaments- ihre
völker präsident von ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir debattieren
heute über den antrag der cdu csu
fraktion für eine wehrhafte demokratie
gegenüber jeglicher art von extremismus
und als ich diesen titel gelesen habe da
dachte ich mir ganz spontan
interessant relevant wichtig und dann
hat sich in meinem hinterkopf plötzlich
ein paar fragen haben sie ein paar
fragen eingestellt und die wichtigste
frage die sich mir gestellt hat war ist
es nicht für alle demokratinnen und
demokraten eine selbstverständlichkeit
für diese unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung einzutreten
sie zu verteidigen gegen jede und jeden
der diese grundordnung in frage stellt
gegen jegliche form der gewalt gegen
jede form des extremismus ja meine damen
das ist eine selbstverständlichkeit und
gerade für diese regierung und die sie
tragenden koalitionsparteien
der neue bericht des bka zeit dass die
zahl der politisch motivierten
gewalttaten insbesondere in den letzten
beiden jahren gestiegen ist das gilt
auch für die gesamtzahl der politisch
motivierten straftaten eine solche
entwicklung dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen
diese zahlen sind nämlich nicht nur
daten sie bedeuten mehr menschen sind
opfer politisch motivierter taten
geworden ihnen muss unsere solidarität
gelten
alle formen des extremismus bis
entschieden entgegengetreten werden
diese passt ist aber nicht bei maßnahmen
zur bekämpfung von symptomen enden
vielmehr müssen wir auch die ursachen
für extremistische orientierungen
angehen es muss gelingen die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
bei den menschen zu verankern das
geplante demokratie fördern gesetzt das
auch schon angesprochen wurde wird ein
wichtiger schritt sein zur erreichung
dieses ziels und dieser schritt ist
notwendig als wissenschafts politiker
der auf drei jahrzehnte praktischer
erfahrung im bildungswesen zurückblicken
kann weiß ich um die bedeutung von
forschung und bildung für
gesellschaftliche entwicklungen
politische bildung kann in allen
lebensphasen dazu beitragen die idee
einer offenen gesellschaft zu verstehen
und daran akzeptanz bei den menschen zu
steigern
freiheit und demokratie sind keine
selbstverständlichkeit
wir müssen ihre grundlagen verstehen wir
müssen ihre vorteile kennen wir müssen
für sie kämpfen und bildung kann
menschen dazu befähigen
es gilt es gilt mehr in forschung über
soziale zusammenhänge krisensicherheit
und resilienz gegenüber extremistischen
entwicklungen zu investieren
eine wissenschaftlich fundierte analyse
bereitet die grundlage für ein
effektives
politisches handeln es gilt zum beispiel
zu verstehen warum sich menschen aus der
gesellschaftlichen mitte während der
korona pandemie radikalisiert haben und
ob sich daraus eine dauerhafte
herausforderung für den zusammenhalt für
unsere gesellschaft und das bekenntnis
zu freiheit und demokratie ergibt
für die koalition geht es nicht darum
nur symptome des extremismus zu
bekämpfen
wir müssen auch die potenziale für einen
weiteren anstieg der zahl extremistisch
denkender und handelnder personen
reduzieren wir müssen die grundlagen
schaffen
wir müssen die grundlagen schaffen dass
extremismus aus unserer gesellschaft
endlich verschwindet und keine weiteren
nährboden in der zukunft hat und dass
mein samen hahn schließt natürlich auch
ein dass jegliches staatliche handeln
dass zum beispiel die grundrechte zur
bekämpfung des extremismus einschränkt
genau auf seine verfassungskonformität
überprüft werden muss
und lassen sie nicht zum schluss
folgendes betonen bei der bekämpfung des
extremismus den rechtsstaatlichkeit und
faktenbasierte entscheidungen grundlage
für erfolg und akzeptanz der maßnahmen
lassen sie uns deshalb bietet den weg
nicht sorry nicht den weg der angst
sondern ein weg der vernunft gehen
vielen dank
stefan seiler aus der fdp fraktion war
der dritte plätze redner in einer
debatte geführt wird auf der grundlage
eines antrags der cdu csu fraktion zum
thema wehrhafte demokratie gegenüber
extremismus und jetzt kommt alexander
hoffmann aus der unionsfraktion der
schon mal eine minute abgezogen bekommen
hat weil seine vorrednerin aus der
unionsfraktion die zeit überzogen hat
und da ist s 2 s 11 20 am freitagmorgen
aber bei solchen themen bei solchen
dingen hat bundestags-vizepräsident
kubicki jetzt schon schlechte laune also
eine minute weniger für alexander
hoffmann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
zuschauer ich möchte zunächst einmal
eine vorbemerkung
platzieren weil ich will ihnen schon
sagen dass mich die heftigkeit der
debatte zum einen überrascht und zum
anderen auch bewegt und da will ich
liebe frau kollegin mich schon auch mal
in ihre richtung etwas persönliches
formulieren wissen sie es ist eigentlich
schon fast mehr als schlechter stil
wenn sie in dem rahmen dieser debatte
den eindruck erwecken und sie haben
sogar ausdrücklich gesagt also die union
trage die verantwortung für dieses
attentat am breitscheidplatz das war ja
nein nein relativieren es ist nicht
relativieren es ist nicht das war das
war die botschaft
und da muss man der vollständigkeit
halber schon einmal dazu sagen der
umstand dass sich der attentäter vom
breitscheidplatz unter dem schirm durchs
gesamte bundesgebiet hat unbehelligt
bewegen können hing zusammen mit einem
sicherheitspolitischen saustall der in
berlin fabriziert worden ist und in
nordrhein-westfalen fabriziert worden
ist und dort haben sie die verantwortung
getragen sein kollege logan an die
zwischenzeitlich im blick
herr präsident
das bringt mir die eine minute zurück
also er hofft man dass was sie mir
gerade vorgeworfen haben das weise ich
erstmal aufs entschiedenste zurück und
wenn sie mich schon zitieren aber dann
bitte ich doch darum dass sie mich bitte
auch richtig zitieren ich habe eine
reihe von rechtsextremistischen
anschlägen aufgezählt ich habe auch den
anschlag auf dem breitscheidplatz
aufgezählt und ich habe dabei gesagt
dass all diese ereignisse in eine zeit
fielen in denen die union hier
verantwortung getragen hat und das ist
ja wohl unbestreitbar hoffmann
wie sie sich jetzt hier hinstellen
können und das was ich gesagt habe so
verdrehen können dass ich ihnen
angeblich vorgeworfen habe dass sie von
der union persönlich für diese attentate
verantwortlich sind dass es einfach
ungeheuerlich und das weiss ich aufs
schärfste zurück erhoffen
wir befinden uns hier in einer
politischen auseinandersetzung und ich
hoffe doch sehr dass wir das auch
weiterhin gemeinsam tun können in der
wir darum ringen was denn die beste
sicherheitspolitik hier für unser land
ist und da muss ich noch einmal
eindringlich an sie appellieren dass sie
sich dann auch bitte zu der
verantwortung die sie die letzten 16
jahre hier in diesem haus und dem
bundesinnenministerium betragen haben
auch bekennen herzlichen dank
frau königin mir alle schauen sie das
ganze haus ist ja nun mal zeuge dessen
gewesen was ich ihr gesagt und jetzt
versuchen sie es jetzt versuchen ist zum
einen relativ zu relativieren und zum
anderen ist es so warum stellen sie denn
genau diesen zusammenhang her und im
übrigen haben sie sehr viel
unmittelbarer formuliert als es jetzt
als es jetzt gerade formuliert haben ich
kann mir vorstellen ich kann mir
vorstellen dass ihnen das echo jetzt weh
getan hat aber wenn sie sich in ihrer
rede wenn sie sich in ihrer rede mit
diesem zusammenhang hier aufs parkett
begeben dann müssen sie genau mit dem
echo reden ich will herr präsident
fortfahren nämlich immer noch
bezüglich der frage der heftigkeit der
debatte warum ist denn die debatte so
heftig die union formuliert einen antrag
deshalb verständlichkeit und wir haben
eigentlich damit gerechnet dass sich die
ampel ganz locker hinter diesem antrag
wird versammeln können das ganz rechts
und ganz links probleme damit hat das
war uns klar aber sie verfallen dann
immer in bestimmte mechanismen die
am schluss die diskussion um die details
und ums konkrete erschweren die zwei
mechanismen die geht immer in die
richtung jeder der
wegschaut beziehungsweise jeder der sich
traut richtung linksextremismus fragen
zu formulieren da kann ja schon kein
aufrechter antifaschisten und der zweite
mechanismus den sie an den tag legen ist
das dann jeder der über andere
extremismus arten in diesem haus reden
bringt das der ja dann gleich den
rechtsextremismus relativiert und
ausdrücklich das tun wir nicht in
unserem antrag wir sind bei ihnen wir
sind bei ihnen
der rechtsextremismus ist für unsere
demokratie die größte gefahr in diesem
land wir unterstützen ihren
zehn-punkte-plan aber wir erlauben uns
den hinweis dass eben genau dieser
ausbaufähig ist weil wir sagen wenn ich
extremismus
effizient bekämpfen will da schauen sie
da geht es wieder los wenn ich
extremismus effizient bekämpfen dann
brauche ich an den breiten blick und ich
brauche einen gut gefüllten
wirksamen instrumentenkasten mit dem
breiten blick meinen wir den 360 grad
blick ich muss neben dem
rechtsextremismus den linksextremismus
im blick haben den islamistischen
extremismus und den anti semitismus und
wenn ich dann über den zweiten großen
baustein rede nämlich den gut bestückten
instrumentenkasten
dann wissen sie dass immer weg mit dem
hinweis auf bürgerrechte und erwecken
hier immer den eindruck dass die union
liederlich mit bürgerrechten und kind
wird auch das ist doch nicht richtig wo
ist denn eigentlich
ihr konkretes gegenargument sie alle
wissen dass wir sehr wohl
grundrechtskonforme
maßnahmen zur aufdeckung von
finanzströmen und zur bekämpfung
politischen islamismus auf den weg
bringen könnte kein argument von ihnen
sie wissen genau dass wir grund
rechtskonform effektive maßnahmen zur
besseren aufklärung in der linksextremen
szene auf den weg bringen könnten wo ist
denn ihr konkretes gegenargument und sie
wissen sehr wohl dass wir auch
grundgesetzkonform staatliche
fördergelder davon abhängig machen
können dass eine organisation die diese
bekommt unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung auch leben
dazu sagen sie konkret nicht sondern es
gibt immer nur den pauschalen hinweis
auf bürgerrechte und da sagen wir ihnen
das ist uns zu wenig deshalb stellen wir
diesen antrag und darüber werden wir
natürlich in der ausschussberatung noch
diskutieren danke für die aufmerksamkeit
alexander hoffmann war das aus der
unionsfraktion hat zu beginn seiner rede
sprache und tonfall in dieser debatte
beklagt hat aber auch von einem ich
zitiere saustall in berlin und
düsseldorf gesprochen und dabei auf die
sozialdemokraten verwiesen jetzt ist ein
sozialdemokrat am pult hell gelähmt
[Musik]
ihre wollte gerade gegenüber der
kollegin match war zutiefst schäbig und
unredlich das muss ich mal festhalten
sie wird wie das protokoll zeigen wird
sie war zudem unwahr und es war die
klassische figur eines wurde bauten und
eines ablenkungsmanövers von ihren
eigenen defiziten dem eigenen scheitern
und
passwörter weise haben sie auch den
beweis geführt dass genau das was wir
die ganze zeit sagen der fall ist
nämlich dieser antrag ist nichts
substanziell aber ist ein rein
parteitaktisches manöver nichts anderes
sie reden ja darin von wehrhafte
demokratie
ich vermisse nur irgendwelche ausführung
zu konzepten zu wehrhafte demokratie in
diesem text
sie
werden sicher ja miterlebt kam auch aus
der pmk aus der statistik zu politisch
motivierter kriminalität was für eine
gewaltige zahl von taten wie im bereich
nicht zuzuordnen haben im zusammenhang
mit querdenken krone etc was für eine
unterminierung der demokratie ich
empfehle ihnen daher dringlich lesen sie
einfach mal ein kurzes interview zb von
kollegen coole da ist in fünf teilen
mehr inhalt als in ihrem gesamten antrag
als wär hinweis
stattdessen
stattdessen führen sie hier dieses vor
und sie zeigen eine reihe von
lehrstellen denn einen konkreten
aktionsplan linksextremismus mit seinen
motiven erkenne ich nicht ebenso wenig
bei der frage des umgangs mit islamismus
irgendwelche innovationen sind
fehlanzeige es nur ein sammelsurium
altbekannte motive und forderung ist es
im grunde ein folkloristischer antrag
mit 0 gehalt und der informationswert
ist nicht darin was er sagt sondern was
er nicht sagt sie sagen ja in ihrem
titel
wehrhafte demokratie und gegenüber
jeglicher art von extremismus also
selbstverständlich kann keiner was dazu
sagen denkt man erst aber es gibt ja
auch so was wie regeln und prinzipien
von sprache semantik pragmatik und die
würden ihnen dann ganz einfach erläutern
dass das eine revolution ist und die
preise position ist die innenministerin
kümmert sich nicht um alle formen von
extremismus und das ist die freiheit und
die unanständigkeit ihres antrages und
da steckt darin
und jetzt werden sie wieder sagen der
lindt kommt mit sprachlichen ausführung
und herr de vries meldet sich
wahrscheinlich wieder wie beim letzten
mal das sei philosophie und
sinnlosigkeit nur wenn es wie sie die
art der analyse die wir betreiben das
fragen nach gründen und die entlarven
ihrer parteitaktische manöver
philosophie ist dann sagt das nichts
über ein philosoph überschuss bei uns
aber über ein eklatantes philosophie
defizit bei ihnen und philosophie
bedeutet ja auch griechische
freundschaft zur weisheit weisheit war
aber bei diesem antrag nicht
federführend
wir müssen des weiteren auch feststellen
und das widerspricht auch dem prinzip
von weisheit dass herr seehofer
innenminister nicht nur am ende seiner
amtszeit vehement für ein thema
demokratie fördergesetz geworben hat
sondern auch endlich richtigerweise ganz
klar bekannte dass die größte gefahr in
diesem land der
somit hat er zwei aufträge erteilt
demokratie fördergesetz und bekämpfung
von rechtsextremismus
frau feser hat diese aufträge intensiv
angegriffen das heißt sie sollten sie
nicht kritisieren sie müssten ein dankes
antrag schreiben dass sie das umsetzt
was ihr eigener minister versprochen hat
stattdessen
stattdessen kommen sie mit
extremismusklausel reloaded demokratie
treueerklärung und es kann mich nicht
wirklich überzeugen wenn sie doch
wirklich eine wehrhafte demokratie
wollen und wenn sie das unterstelle ich
in demokratie fördern wollen dass sie
dann ein angriff fahren gegen die
demokratie verteidigen und fördern mit
angriffen auf demokratie vorderen
fördert man logischerweise nicht die
demokratie und stellen sie sich doch mal
die situation vor von verein institution
in landstrichen in denen die als die
dominant ist die da schafften gegen
querdenker gegen querulanten der
unmenschlichkeit gegen selbstverwaltung
usw stellen sie sich mal die situation
vollauf sie lagen diese in einem raum
und dann legen sie diesen antrag vor was
sie sagen müssten es wir bekräftigen ihr
tun wir unterstützen ist wir verstetigen
die forderung stattdessen ist ihre
message wir vertrauen euch nicht ihr
seid ja latent linksextrem und ihr steht
nicht auf dem boden der verfassung ich
finde das ist absolut unanständig auch
gegenüber diesen vorkämpfer für
demokratie
deshalb brauchen wir für demokratie
förderung in der tat ein demokratie
fordern gesetzt und sie sollten die
ersten die sich dafür einsetzen das ist
sowieso ein täuschungsmanöver warum
erwecken sie den eindruck
aktivistischer einsatz
zivilgesellschaftliche einsatz für
demokratie gegen rechtsextremismus wäre
verdächtigt des linksextremismus ist
doch absurd demokratie förderung ist
weder links noch rechts weder liberal
noch konservativ das sollte uns doch
alle einen sie sollten als erste auch
als konservativer aufstehen und sagen
wir wollen ein funktionierendes
demokratie fördergesetz und das zweite
und letzte
sie können der richtigerweise ein
aktionsprogramm und sonstwas gegen
islamismus fordern aber was ist denn mit
den ganz vielen normalen muslimischen
menschen oder solche die so gelesen
werden wahrgenommen werden die lesen im
landtag nichts über antimuslimischer
rassismus nicht über ihre
alltagserfahrungen täglich diskriminiert
zu werden aber sie müssen sich mit dem
vorwurf des islamismus ausgesetzt
beschluss sage ihnen wenn sie
konzeptuell erfolgreich gegen islamismus
arbeiten sollen dann dürfen sie nicht
über antimuslimischen rassismus und
formen von fremdenfeindlichkeit und
integrationsfeindlich und ähnlicher
stigmatisierung schweigen will gegen sie
wirklich islamismus bekämpfen sollen
dann kämpfen sie auch gegen rassismus
lernen sie daraus vielen dank
soweit der demokratiepolitische sprecher
der spd fraktion im deutschen bundestag
lehnt und das war dann für heute die
beratung zu diesem antrag der
unionsfraktion für eine wehrhafte
demokratie gegenüber jeglicher art von
extremismus
der antrag wird jetzt an die
entsprechenden ausschüsse wiesen